Richard welcome to Croatia how did it
happen that you've never been here
before you were living not so far away I
guess oh yes uh yeah actually I was
always doing very close yeah I always
find this triangle around the aranzagra
but somehow I managed to to avoid this
so far yeah I don't know well as you
know life always brings you to places so
now I'm here yeah yeah so here we are
now in zagrebent to what let's say your
expectations here in for this event and
in general in this grandchester
oh I'm I don't think I'm doing too well
in this country store on a cell and look
at your standings but like I had some
solid performances but I feel like so
it's not good enough in grantchester
terms so
um yeah again if I would if it were to
change here in Zagreb it wouldn't hurt
too much if I would have some really
good performance but as of expectation I
I don't really have any you know
spectacular expectations just trying to
play chess and trying to you know save
my use my remaining energy reserves and
see what happens here yeah we were
talking about
and then Serbia now and you were from
Hungary and now I think you live in
Romania right and you're going to play
for the Romanian team and what do you
think impact it had on your life and on
your profession as a Jasper to live in
all these countries have you got
something from each of this country of a
niche of this culture yes and Croatia is
next
sure yeah you know okay I was obviously
I'm born and raised in Hungary more or
less so
my even my especially my chess culture I
think is very much shaped shaped by that
um yeah then obviously I moved to Serbia
and I was kind of a young adult and so
therefore my my development as a person
I think it's very much shaped by Western
culture and and generally the life in
Belgrade I really enjoy it I really like
the atmosphere there so I always
recommend it for for people who tourists
who are found during what to visit
because okay it doesn't have such a
reputation as a touristic destination
but I feel like the the people are just
so nice it's it's compensated here you
know and now bucharesti abucharest is a
bit I'm I'm still unfamiliar with it in
a way because okay I'm very new there
I'm very new in Romania
um you know obviously it was kind of um
commitment from my part and I will see
how it will work out
um I'm still adjusting so yeah that's uh
that is unknown for now yes and um well
of course everybody's wondering that
you're still in touch with dingley Wren
and when what's happening with him after
the match and when we are going to see
him again let's say do you have any news
from him
I have as much news as the next guy yeah
so
yeah I sometimes feel very right to each
other but he's a very close guy and I
think he's he's you know
I hope he's doing what he likes to do
yeah let's put it this way yeah that's
the most important actually to do what
you like to do in your life and actually
how do you find this balance between
being a professional chess player and
trying to do things which you really
like to do and have healthy life if
possible yeah I mean being a
professional chess player generally
um gives you this freedom of the
illusion of freedom to have you know
let's say a Monday morning yeah where
everyone's at work and you just wake up
whenever you want to wake up and do
whatever you like to do right so it is
generally I think because it's my
expectations from Life very well of
course when you go to a tournament and
it's totally different like for instance
I'm here talking to you right
not sleeping yes so okay it's kind of
balances itself out I guess at the end
um yeah so for me it's always been a bit
of a challenge to to balance it I guess
I've been playing uh maybe a little bit
too much for my standards enroll and I'm
already longing for for a break and uh
some small location but other than that
you know it's more or less fine yeah
only five days to go very exciting chess
I mean I wish you all the best of luck
and to still find some energy for
fantastic games you you play always
we're looking forward for it thank you
Richard thanks
[Music]